Ora
Ara
sambud
saran.
sangми
du
bant
Pam
saran
P
சரமி
PBAN
Saran
ตมан
ติ
sangнan
saran
namato
arahat
sambud
sex
погипне
Candr
Graz
honra benzar. Gurup
honra
gurup
Grupon
honom
Grup
honra
grup
honra romar
gurup de rom honra romar
grup
honra romar
Grup
de rom honra romara
grup
honra romar
gurup
de
honra
gurup
Hrazar
rom honom
gurup
de rom
hon rar
gurup
honom
Grup
honra romar
grup
sidom
honra romzara
gurup
Rom honra romar
grup
honra romar
honra romzara
grup
honra romar
honra rzar
Grup
r honra romzar
grup
hon romzar
hon romar
grup
honom
Hrazar
honra romar
gurup
rom
honom
grup.
Gurup
honra
gurup
Grup
honra romar
gurup
romar
de rom honom
gurup
romar
gurup de romar
Romar
gurup
romar
honra
gurup
gurup.
Hrazar
gurup
honra
grup
hon
Grup de rom.
Hra romar
gur de rom. Honra romar
gur
de rom honra
grup
honra romanar
gur
de rom.
Grup.
Honra
Grup
honra
grupar
gurup.
Gupz
gurup
honom
Grup
honrzar
grup
honra romz
honra romzará
grup
honra romzara
gurup
rom honra romzará
gurupidrom.
Grazar
honra romar
de romar
gur
Paraga
tempar
Baga
paraanga
sanga
S가
Ga
para sang
para
God.
Parang
paraanga
가га
arang
ரang
Paraga
tempar
Baga
sangте
paraгаang
G
parang
Gaang
ang
Eh,
eh,
para s
band
Steang
S
a
agora página 20.
através de homenagens, oferendas,
confissão, regozijo, solicitação e
súplica. Qualquer pequeno mérito que eu
tenha gerado, dedico a que todos possam
alcançar a iluminação.
A terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
sumero os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros.
A terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros. A
terra está ungida com água perfumada e
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico,
seres usufruir dos reinos puros
guru na mandala niria tai
para fazer as necessidades de todos os
seres em seus diversos níveis de
compreensão, solicitamos que você roda
do dharma, incluindo as abordagens
menores e maiores comuns e
extraordinárias.
Através deste mérito, que todos os seres
possam se tornar oniscientes e alcançar
o estado búdico, derrotando todas as
faltas e impedimentos.
Que todos os seres possam ser liberados
do oceano da existência condicionada,
agitado pelas ondas do nascimento, da
velice, doença e da morte.
Então, a gente tá chegando ao final
e
agora
resta ainda ah a gente examinar os sete
fatores da iluminação, que foi
justamente o que ficou assim pra
conclusão do Satipatana Sutra, né?
Então aí
o Buda começa
novamente bicos. Um bico permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais referente referentes aos
sete fatores da iluminação.
Então esse é um ponto assim
super importante, né, que a gente não
pode perder perspectiva.
Ah, o bico permanece contemplando
os objetos mentais como objetos mentais.
agora
focando sete fatores da iluminação.
Então ele tá colocando os sete fatores
da iluminação como objetos mentais,
pessoal. Então isso poderia, isso pode
surgir assim como a iluminação
eh
objeto objeto mental.
aquilo surge, cessa,
né? Então é exatamente isso. Então ele
vai colocar os sete fatores da
iluminação como alguma coisa que nós
vamos ficar independentes,
né? Então eu acho isso completamente
maravilhoso, completamente radical
também né?
Isso naturalmente tá conectado a várias
outras descrições também que são
semelhantes, mas aqui tem um nível de
radicalidade porque ele dá um nome para
tudo, vai lá e agora medita assim e pom,
né? Assim. Então eu acho isso muito
extraordinário.
Ele poderia dizer: "Pessoal, agora vamos
ficar, vamos relaxar. Agora nós vamos
focar os sete fatores da iluminação, vão
atingir iluminação
e aí ele se segura lá. Mas não, ele tá
transmitindo a mente búdica,
só que a transmissão da mente
com uma clareza
muito grande, né?
Então ele tá
é é semelhante ao Tapuça Sutra também.
Na verdade, o o Satipatana ele também
ele ele
ele se relaciona com outros sutas que
exploram um pouco mais alguma coisa, um
pouco mais outra coisa, né?
Então, ah, mas essencialmente todos
esses sutas eles
eles convergem para esse ponto, né?
E o ponto que a gente poderia eh
descrever
é justamente visão,
porque quando o Buda descreve isso e se
mantém independente,
ele tá descrevendo o que? Ele tá
exercendo visão.
E essa visão é independente de qualquer
treinamento,
essa visão, ela é alguma coisa que nos
mantém livres das múltiplas
configurações que as coisas possam
ganhar a partir de objetos mentais. Eu
não, não é me fixar em objetos mentais,
pessoal.
Isso não é uma coisa muito fácil de
entender.
Tá certo que a gente tá trabalhando isso
o tempo todo, né? Então, por exemplo,
nós estamos dentro prágina paramita, que
é o início para nós. Dentro prágina
paramita não há sabedoria, por exemplo,
né?
Mas há confiança no prágina paramita.
Confiança no quê? em que isso não é em
que isso é vacuidade.
Da vacuidade isso surge.
Por outro lado, a confiança de que na
vacuidade não há nem sabedoria,
né? É assim. Então esse é o ponto.
Obrigada.
Obrigada. Então isso super especial,
pessoal. Isso converge direto para a
natural perfeição,
no aspecto mais sofisticado da natural
perfeição, porque são três níveis, né?
Ou seja, nada a fazer. Esse é o aspecto
mais o mais o aspecto introdutório é a
análise
sobre o aspecto último do aspecto último
que revela o aspecto último.
O aspecto assim de transição é eu
atravessar
o engano.
>> E o aspecto último é nada a fazer.
Então, nada a fazer é justamente
a simplesmente a visão natural
não fabricada
que nós podemos
deslizar para descrever como a confiança
na visão ou confiança no prágio na
paranita. Enquanto algo não construído,
algo completamente natural.
Esse
esse essa transmissão que o Buda dá, o
estilo de transmitir isso nos nicaias,
nos ensinamentos antigos dele,
é um é um estilo muito limpo, assim, né?
muito limpo, no sentido de que não tem
nem essas palavras que eu tô falando
aqui.
Ele vai descrevendo
as coisas mais sutis e vai dizer que ele
vai falar da independência.
Do mesmo modo, por exemplo, no Tapuça
suta, o Buda vai descrever os vários
janas né?
Então ele descreve um por um dos estados
meditativos.
E aí ele vai descrever isso como
pertencendo ao mundo do desejo, da forma
e da não forma.
E aí ele descreve a Niroda,
que é o que seria assim pros meditantes
é como se fosse a a radicalidade, né?
Os meditantes, eles não saberam pensar
numa radicalidade maior do que niroda,
que é essencialmente a interrupção da
operação da mente. Aí tu desliga, puxa a
chave geral,
zerou.
Aí medictante tá num escurão
tenso,
rígido fixado
virginianamente,
com a sensação de chegou a algum lugar.
E esse lugar ele seria descrito como
coisa nenhuma ou em dialeto africano,
belelu
assim. Aí no lugar, seja não tem nada
lá.
Aí pensa pá, atingir o resultado.
Pessoal em roda também não é. Aí o Buda
se dá conta. Por quê? Porque tem um
vermezinho dentro do Buda,
tem alguma coisa que roi lá dentro e
diz: "Pá, isso é tudo construído."
É o, enfim, é o verme filosófico do
Buda. Tá lá, não, isso aí também é
construído, isso aí não dá, não tem
como.
E então esse é o ponto. Aí o Boda disse:
"Eu tô liberto". de entrar em estados
mentais particulares.
Então o liberto é isso, pessoal. Faltou
essa partezinha liberto
de estados mentais particulares.
Aí ele continua: "Os filósofos não, essa
parte é uma transmissão mais recente
assim, um terma.
Então esse é o ponto, né?
Então aqui também aí tu vai olhando, tu
segue o caminho de virginana, né?
Sutilizando, meditando e sutilizando,
meditando sutilizando
e tu te liberta de toda a formulação e
de todo o caminho junto também.
Te liberta dos sete fatores da
iluminação. Ele diz aqui como é que tu
treina os sete fatores e aí depois tu te
mantém independente disso,
né? Isso aqui é assim, é o fim do CEB.
E aí não vou meditar o que, pessoal?
Tô dizendo isso e já vou embora. Vou
deixar a bomba com vocês,
hein, V? Eu v editar o quê agora?
Que vai ficar aqui?
explica meditação para eles aí que
maravilhoso isso aí. O Bod vai dizer:
"Se você praticar isso por sete
vidas,
poder atinge a iluminação." Eu achei
aquilo maravilhoso, na barbada, né? Sete
vida,
a gente quer o quê? A gente não quer
voltar, voltar, voltar. Sete. Tá bom.
Mas depois ele faz como o Trump, ele dá
uma
milha alivia.
Então, novamente, bicos, um bico
permanece contemplando os objetos
mentais com objetos mentais
referente aos sete fatores da
iluminação.
E como um bico permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais
referentes aos sete fatores da
iluminação.
aqui estando presente nele o fator da
iluminação da tensão plena. Então vocês
pensem, pessoal, a gente
vamos obter a tensão plena ou um bico
compreende. O fator da iluminação da
tensão plena está em mim.
ou se o fator da iluminação da tensão
plena não estiver presente nele, ele
compreende
o fator da iluminação da tensão plena
não está em mim.
Ele também compreende como estimular o
fator da iluminação da tensão plena.
Então essa parte de ele olhar para
dentro e ver, não, isso tá em mim, isso
não tá em mim, isso parece do John
Ripochet, ele tá descrevendo rig. Como é
que tu olha para dentro e vê se aquilo
tá ou não tá?
Como é que vê?
Então ele sabe.
Por quê? Porque o fator da iluminação da
tensão plena,
ele é uma disposição mental. Então,
disposição mental eh criada, a própria
mente sabe se aquilo tá ali ou não.
Mas, por exemplo, se ele tiver pensando
em outra coisa, ele não tiver capacidade
de chamata,
ele nem segue, porque ele começa um
pouco, já salta para outra coisa.
É assim. Então chama até necessário,
senão tu não consegue. Chama até
necessário.
Que tem as pessoas que acham que não
precisa chama.
É assim, é tão interessante isso, né?
Porque tu não precisa de caminho, mas tu
precisa de caminho. Seu caminho é um
obstáculo,
mas ao mesmo tempo tu precisa de
caminho.
É, com certeza. É isso.
É, tem o Aí tu vai entrar nos Janas, aí
tem o sutra do tem o Jana sutra que tu
vai descobrindo o engano de cada jana.
Aquilo é assim, é, eu
não gosto de achar que as coisas são
tristes, né? Mas elas eu acho um pouco
triste assim. Triste o quê?
Triste é o fato de que a gente quando se
engaja em alguma coisa, a gente acredita
que aquilo vai se somar. É como se
tivesse fazendo uma viagem, tu põe na
tua bagagem. Não, isso eu levo junto,
né? Mas não, pessoal, aquilo são
trechos,
mas isso não tem, a gente não tem essa
sensação. A gente tem a sensação que a
gente tá adquirindo coisas, né? Por quê?
Porque nós estamos focados na estética
da identidade. A identidade vai chegar
em algum lugar. Eu tô aprendendo coisas,
tô me fixando, obrigada.
Tô me fixando em algumas coisas que têm
sentido, elas são verdadeiras,
né? Então eu vou seguir aquilo.
Sim. Então nós vamos botar. Eu não
acredito em atenção plena. Vai aumentar
essa coisa. Eu não acredito. Vai
aumentar.
Assim
agora não acreditar em atenção plena é
horrível né?
Então a gente tem um apegozinho, né,
pessoal? Vamos pensar assim, né? Nós já
temos um apegozinho na na tensão plena.
Então, mas aí o Buda até explica, né?
Por quê? Porque esse é o caminho dos
bicos. O caminho dos becos vai
desenvolver os sete fatores da
iluminação.
Assim.
Então, um bico compreende o fator da
iluminação da tensão plena está em mim.
Ou se o fator da iluminação da tensão
plena não estiver nele, ele compreende.
O fator da iluminação da tensão plena
não está em mim. Ele também compreende
como estimular o fator da iluminação da
da tensão plena que não está estimulado.
E como o fator da iluminação da tensão
plena que está estimulado
alcança a sua plenitude através do
desenvolvimento. Então ele tum
desenvolveu a tensão plena.
Esse os sete fatores da iluminação,
eles têm, por exemplo, um dos sintomas
do problema, já vou explicar para você
isso, isso tá apontado pelos tibetanos,
né?
Ah, é assim, se a gente desenvolve a
tensão plena,
alcança a plenitude através do
desenvolvimento da tensão plena, como
isso é algo
construído
e foi construído com esforço,
nós temos uma fixação.
Isso aqui foi transmitido e foi
construído. Então isso se torna algo
sólido.
Quando se torna algo sólido, surge
inevitavelmente
uma fixação. Essa fixação, ela vai
causar um pouco de perturbação,
porque ela causa uma ah ela tem um
elemento terra que constrói a
identidade.
Onde tem a fixação, tem elemento terra.
Se não tem um elemento terra, eu vou me
fixar onde eu tenho alguma coisa que eu
vejo como terra. Eu me fixo. Quando eu
me fixo, eu tenho uma base pro
surgimento de identidade.
Essa identidade ela pode gerar mais
adiante
só queung os tibetanos vão descrever,
né? Isso não é uma coisa incomum.
As pessoas que entram em retiro, elas
podem desenvolver só que lung num certo
momento né?
Tem um fator de perturbação mental que
eu não sei descrever o nome,
mas ele é mais sutil do que a
identidade.
E ele é um embrião da identidade,
né? E naturalmente ele se esconde dentro
de várias aparências,
mas o que acontece é assim, não importa
qual a identidade que tu derruba,
ressurge ou ou se mantém oculto
o o elemento que busca
ressurgir na forma de uma identidade. É
como se não houvesse uma operação mental
possível que não fosse através da sétima
consciência aí de uma bolha. Então nós
ficamos procurando outra bolha.
Ou seja, é um impulso de renascimento
que não tem uma aparência. Se tu tirar
todas as aparências onde o renascimento
possa aparecer,
isso não mata
essa dimensão. Ela fica procurando uma
outra forma e ela pode, por exemplo,
aspirar, renascer, é tipo niroda,
entende? OK, não é nada, então eu fico
no nada, mas eu tô lá.
Como tem esse aspecto, esse aspecto
produz
uma
aparência de terra. Essa aparência de
terra ela
me dá uma ancoragem por um movimento de
energia a partir dessa Terra. Então esse
movimento de energia a partir da Terra,
ele vai produzir Sock Lung. Só que Lungo
é um nome delicado dos tibetanos para
loucura.
Ah,
o padana é como se fosse um uma dança
aqui. É como se fosse uma raiz que
conduz ao padana.
Tu tira a identidade, tira a árvore,
tira todos os frutos e fica alguma coisa
lá
entrincherada, querendo que tudo
ressurja.
Como
>> pode ser
surge isso aí. Vai. Quais são os
sintomas de sock long? Aí vocês vão ver
assim,
é que aqui eu comecei com atenção plana
e deslizei para esse aspecto, mas os
cinco, os sete vão produzir isso, porque
os sete vão me dar certeza. Quando me
dão certeza, significa que a que a terra
começa a se consolidar.
Aí eu consolido aquela terra, aí eu
tenho ah aí o sintoma é assim: Tu não
ouve mais nada.
Tu tem certeza,
é, como é uma terra muito sutil, tu
descarta qualquer crítica, porque as
críticas tu diz: "Não, mas isso aqui é
é muito
é muito primário.
Então, surge um lugar difícil de ser
removido. O sintoma final é que tu não,
a guru yoga desaparece.
E o desaparecimento de guru yoga, ele
pode surgir eh como se fosse uma guru
yoga,
que então é uma armadilha e tanto, né?
assim, não, eu tô rendido em guru yoga e
eu vejo isso, vejo aquilo, vejo tal
coisa, isso. Mas é de estar preso nas
nos vários,
nos vários elementos que surgiram dentro
do próprio
processo de meditação e treinamento, que
surgiram como se fosse uma terra que te
dá certeza. E tu não percebe que tu
surgisse com uma identidade baseada em
certezas sutis que são construídas.
assim. E aí tu rejeita todo e qualquer
outro tipo de argumento. Tu não a tua a
tua,
como é que eu vou dizer?
Tua terra, o local onde tu te coloca,
ele se torna ah quase inexpugnável. Eu
diria assim, quase porque dentro vai
surgir os obstáculos do mundo da não
forma, como por exemplo, vai surgir
vaidade que a pessoa vai percebendo.
Ela pode dizer: "Uá, mas eu tenho uma
vaidade, eu tenho um traço de vaidade."
A pessoa vai perceber que existe uma
intranquilidade.
Por quê? Porque qualquer ser que tá
fixado a alguma
verdade convencional
tem intranquilidade.
A vaidade vem por conta que seja o que
vier que possa ser desafiador, a pessoa
considera que aquilo é
inferior, que ela tá vendo mais do que o
outro.
E
então surge uma incapacidade de olhar,
mas essa incapacidade é assim: "Não, eu
tô refugiado no boda".
assim eh
e aí surge uma incapacidade de goruga,
de fato, no sentido de que, ah, ah, h a
dúvida, porque a o obstáculo para guru
yoga é a dúvida.
Eu vou explicar isso assim, como que
isso se coloca, porque existe a dúvida
pessoal e existe a dúvida impessoal. A
mais sutil é a dúvida impessoal. A
dúvida impessoal surge quando a gente
diz: "Bom, é tudo vazio, porém
aí nós temos alguma coisa que tá ali de
fato e nós acreditamos naquilo e nós
podemos determinar esses fatores a
partir de
de uma terra que a gente cria a partir
de uma experiência muito sutil.
Eu
acho que na própria linguagem que a
gente vai olhando, às vezes a gente pode
pensar: "Bom, a iluminação é individual,
eu me torno
dharmacaia
e aí quando eu me torno darmacaia, o que
que acontece comigo?"
Então tem algumas
questões assim, mas o Buda aqui ele ele
não deixa espaço porque ele vai oferecer
essas várias experiências que podem
aparecer pelo próprio treinamento. E ele
vai dizer que nós vamos olhar isso, nós
vemos isso surgir, sucessar,
nós vemos isso
e nós somos independentes disso.
Isso eu considero que é uma limpeza
super extraordinária, porque toda
linguagem
que é tal que eu atinjo alguma coisa é
uma linguagem que tem um uma pequena um
pequeno obstáculo.
Então, mesmo a linguagem da natural
perfeição é uma linguagem na qual eu vou
galgando muitos e anas, eu vou subindo
até que eu vou chegar numa certa coisa
extraordinária que finalmente limpa, não
tem nada dentro, etc. Mas eu fui
galgando, entendeu? Então, tem uma
sensação muito sutil de que tem alguém
percorrendo alguma coisa.
E aqui não tem dúvida nenhuma. Tudo que
nós estamos percorrendo são situações
ainda sofisticadas que eu preciso
treinar, senão não chego passar por ali,
não chego ver aquilo, mas aquilo tudo
são construções que eu vou classificar
como como construç como ligadas ao corpo
ou ligadas à mente, né? E o corpo e a
mente também não se separam. Eu vou ver
tudo isso como
como construções
e artificialidades, né? Aqui no caso, a
expressão que a gente vai usar é objetos
mentais né?
Eu acho num certo sentido um pouco
frustrante também, né? Porque eu
gostaria de atingir os sete estados da
iluminação e ganhar sete luzes e flutuar
no espaço junto com sete luzes e mais
algumas outras, né? E aquilo seria uma
glória. E as luzes douradas, luzes
maravilhosas, né? Agora eu fiquei um
pouco frustrado porque, enfim,
mas como nós temos essa essa tendência a
buscar uma reificação numa identidade,
a gente passa por um risco
e esse risco ele tá descrito assim, né?
Eu acho que o caminho Marraiana também,
eu não quero aqui também criar polêmica,
eu vou falar isso depois já vou puxar as
palavras, vou negar tudo. Não, não falei
isso, mesmo que esteja gravado foi e
inteligência artificial.
Se alguém insistir, não foi você mesmo,
digo: "Não, foi uma inteligência
artificial implantada, não fui eu."
Obrigada.
É assim, Caminho Marena, pessoal.
tem 10 bumies
e eu me lasco para entrar no primeiro.
Aí é muito difícil passar pro segundo.
Aí eu vou indo, vou indo, vou indo. Aí
quando eu chego no sexto eu penso:
"Agora sim foi o fim". Né? Então,
entendi o sutra do diamante, cheguei em
prágna, agora de
só para entender que não,
que aí tem o sexto boom, a gente
encontrou prágina, mas a gente deixa a
prágina estacionada do lado e trata a
vida como a vida é. De vez em quando a
gente puxa o Prajna e Ah, oi, Prajna,
você tá bem? Tô. Então fica aí. Aí nós
vamos seguindo a vida, porque a vida é a
vida.
Isso é o sexto boom. Ainda assim,
pessoal, no sétimo boom
é assim, quando as coisas acontecem, aí
tu puxa, não, prágina, o que que você
acha disso?
Aí prágina dá um palpite diz: "Ah, tá
tudo bem, então vamos fazer assim ou
não?"
Né? Então, até o sétimo bome pode virar
de cabeça para baixo e voltar para os
infernos.
Por quê? Porque tu não usa prágina
sempre, tu não tem a visão sempre. Aí
vem o oitavo boom
ao qual tu não retorna mais.
Então no oitavo boom,
prágina opera dentro.
Então você opera com prágina. É como se
é o ponto onde a visão
ela se consolidou,
né?
Então seria assim, houve uma
estabilização da visão,
uma familiaridade com a visão. Então a
visão se tornou
permanente. A gente não tem assim, eu
vou olhar um pouco pelo sansara e um
pouco por pela visão. Não, a visão
penetra o sansara, ela não atrapalha a
operação comum. E a visão ficou clara.
Aí vem o nono,
nono boom, no qual
que a gente poderia dizer que é que é
fruição, né? Então o Buda ele se move de
uma moda, já vou dizer o Buda, né?
Porque é isso, é o Tatágata. É o Buda.
Nono, nono boom é o Tatágata. Então
tatágata ele, ele é aquele que vem e
vai. Isso é super profundo, pastor. A
gente pensa, não, o Tatágata vem vindo,
ele vem caminhando, aí depois o Tatágata
vai indo. Pessoal, o Tatágata ele não
vem caminhando, ele entra nos mundos e e
surge noutro mundo e surge noutro mundo
e surge noutro mundo. Os mundos não são
constituídos de de
locais geográficos. Os mundos eles são
todos sutis. Aí o tatgata é aquele que
salta de um mundo pro outro, assim, ele
surge nos vários mundos. Ele é capaz de
chegar nos mundos com uma aparência que
os seres vem ele, ele fala ali, se
comunica ali dentro, porque a aparência
desses mundos, ela não precisa de um
corpo denso.
Os mundos são todos mundos sutis, mesmo
que os seres que estão nesses mundos
sutis têm corpos diferentes.
Mas o Buda ou se comunica lá por dentro
ou eh ele não o o aspecto externo, ele
não tem a capacidade de de se comunicar.
É como nós, por exemplo, eh por exemplo,
se a gente vai falar as quatro nobres
verdades para as pessoas, pode ser que
as pessoas simplesmente não ouçam.
Por quê? Porque não basta eles usarem
olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato
para serem
para que a comunicação aconteça.
Comunicação, ela se dá num nível sutil,
ela não vem assim. Então não é o corpo
grosseiro do Buda que vai permitir a
conexão. Isso se dá num nível sutil, é o
corpo sutil. O Buda num para um mundo
sutil correspondente lá dentro. Ele fala
isso. Se ele tiver um corpo como um
nermancaia que ele vai lá e se
manifesta, pode ser que funcione. Mas o
próprio Buda Saquiam com o corpo dele em
muitos lugares ele falou, não foi
entendido também. É assim. Por quê?
porque simplesmente
não foi possível acessar aquela região
sutil daqueles séries, né? É assim.
Então esse esse é o ponto assim, esse é
o lugar aonde as coisas acontecem nesse
nível sutil, né? Então aí nós temos o
tatágata, depois disso nós temos
dharmamega,
né? Então, dar uma mega eh por vezes
também é descrito desse modo, é essa
inteligência que é capaz de viver a
multiplicidade de mundos.
E ah, às vezes isso é descrito também
havendo um 11º boom, depois do 10º tem
mais um.
E esse 11º
ele ele corresponde a darmacaia no
sentido de ausência de flutuações e de
formas, né? Mas quando a gente ouve uma
descrição dessas, nem sempre a gente se
alegra muito.
A gente diz: "Bom, até o sexto boom,
sétimo eu ainda tudo bem, porque aí eu
uso isso, volto pro mundo e ando por
aqui, por ali, aí tudo bem. agora
oitavo, nono, assim, eu seria o quê?
Então, quero algum tipo de garantia,
né? Então, tem um pouco de aflição
e tem essa questão de nós irmos de um
nível pro outro. A gente tem uma
sensação
que é sustentada pela própria descrição,
que nós estamos indo de um lugar pro
outro, vocês entendem?
Então, a pessoa entrou no primeiro boom,
pessoal, isso já é muito extraordinário.
A pessoa entrou no primeiro no boa já
tem uma sensação de felicidade, de
alegria imediata.
É assim, primeiro boom, tudo de bom,
só falta mais nove, mas estamos indo
bem. Mas o que eu tô aqui descrevendo é
que quando vem uma descrição mahraiana,
nós temos uma sensação de que tem alguém
cumprindo etapas e galgando,
galgando excelências até o ponto final.
Mas quando nós estamos olhando aqui no
nos ensinamentos dos nicas, não tem
isso.
É isso que eu tô trazendo. Então eu eu
tô colocando a visão dos nicas como
superior à visão que pode brotar.
Não, não vou dizer assim que a prática
que brota do Mahaiana e dos outros
caminhos não seja efetiva e não produza
o resultado final. Não é isso. Eu tô
dizendo aqui, a descrição
dos nicas me parece muito perfeita,
muito limpa, no sentido que ela não cria
expectativas,
ela não me projeta em direção a uma
sensação de que eu sou uma identidade
chegando em alguma coisa.
Pelo contrário, ele vai descrever as
várias situações e vai nos colocar no na
posição de de não se vincular com os
aspectos que possam brotar do próprio
caminho.
Enquanto que nas outras abordagens eu
tenho uma sensação de que eu preciso me
vincular em cada parte que eu vou, eu
coloco alguma coisa na minha bolsa.
Então eu vou colocando, por exemplo,
eu vou colocando generosidade,
moralidade,
paz, energia constante, concentração,
sabedoria prágna. Eu vou colocando isso
tudo na minha bolsa. Eu não tenho a
sensação de que a generosidade que eu
coloquei na bolsa, eu deveria depois
dissolver.
Eu tenho a sensação que eu deveria
guardar. Então, o Buda é alguém que tem
uma generosidade perfeita, tem a
perfeição da generosidade, perfeição da
moralidade, ainda que a perfeição, como
descrita no sutra do diamante, ela seja
ah,
seria assim a generosidade, que é
generosidade, não é generosidade,
é alguma coisa assim. Aí no final, se a
pessoa praticou muito generosidade, a
pessoa diz: "Não,
não há generosidade,
não há moralidade". Ela vai dizer isso,
mas ela ela tem uma sensação ainda de
que ela chegou em alguma coisa muito
sutil, onde a generosidade mesmo não é
uma generosidade.
E essa é a verdadeira generosidade.
Mas tem uma sensação de que agora eu
botei na bolsa a generosidade
verdadeira, aquela que nem generosidade
é.
Aí tu vai indo, mas tu tem uma sensação
que tu tem uma bolsa que tu vai
colocando aquilo,
né? E quando tu chega no final, aí tu
tem um portal, tu tem que mostrar aquilo
tudo. Se tu não mostrar aquilo, tu não
cruza o portão.
Mas a estética dos nicaias não é assim.
A estética dos nicaias é assim. Cada
coisa que tu pega e põe na bolsa,
mesmo que tu alcance aquilo ou a
plenitude daquilo através do
desenvolvimento,
aquele aspecto te mantém independente,
livre. O que que significa se manter
independente? A mente é livre. Se eu
chamar isso de mente,
eu tô falciando os nicaias, porque os
nicaias o Buda não vai dizer isso, mas
ele vai dizer uma independência da visão
diante disso. A visão não se prende
nisso. Então a nossa visão não vai se
prender nenhum dos sete fatores da
iluminação. A nossa fixação nos sete
fatores da iluminação impediria a
própria iluminação. seria mais ou menos
isso,
porque elas são são estruturas que eu
vou chamar de objetos mentais.
E aí eu de novo comento esse aspecto que
eu tava trazendo. Se eu me fixar nos
objetos mentais que eu atingia a
plenitude através do desenvolvimento, eu
posso colocar uma terra nisso e surjo
como uma identidade e nego
dizer os ensinamentos estão equivocados
porque evidente isso conduz a uma
existência. No caso, eu mesma,
eu sou a glória. Aí, pronto.
Aí tu não ouve mais os ensinamentos e te
torna incapaz de ver o aspecto mais
sutil, que é o aspecto livre da mente,
que derruba todos os aspectos
construídos e tu te fixa numa
identidade.
Entendeu?
Em outros tempos eu diria, entendeu,
Tatã? Mas agora não digo assim, mas
retirei.
Pode
>> o Lama trazendo essa
tudo isso sobre a fixação do elemento
terra. Será que o nosso maior obst até
anotei aqui a perguntinha, não, para não
me perder. Será que
>> a Tatá chega no último dia e ainda quer
fazer a pergunta? Tom esse, Tatá. Será
que o nosso maior obstáculo é querer
explicar a experiência?
Porque tudo que a gente quer explicar,
me parece que esse tá descrevendo, ele
ele gostaria de explicar e e negar os
ensinamentos, porque ele tem uma
explicação,
>> é, porque tem tem uma identidade fixada
em aspectos de sabedoria que ele
desenvolveu.
É muito parecido com a estrutura, é
muito parecida com a estrutura dos
janas.
Estrutura dos janas, pessoal. Eu espero
poder mais adiante aqui nesse nessa
terra que
a gente percorrer com cuidado o caminho
dos janas.
O nosso destino aqui é seguir o caminho
dos janas, que é o caminho ilusório dos
Jonas. É bom botar assim, porque eh é
como aqui o caminho ilusório dos sete
fatores da iluminação.
Por que ilusório? Porque eu vou criar
isso, mas eu preciso me livrar disso. E
os janas é a estrutura é a mesma. Só que
em vez de eu entrar pelos fatores da
iluminação, eu entro por estados mentais
meditativos mais e mais sutis e eu vou
derrubando um por um.
E eu vou ficar com o quê?
Nós vamos ficar com a lucidez que
derrubou um por um dos estados
meditativos,
indo até o mais sutil.
Esse é o caminho dos janas.
pela própria experiência. Quando tu
mergulha na experiência de alguma coisa
particular, tu te livra. Mas essa essa
descrição, ela não tá correta. Isso que
eu tô falando. Porque eu digo, você
entra nisso e aí você se você sai disso
e você quem?
Entende? Mas na falta de alguma coisa,
aí é assim, aí tu diz: "Ó, você, mas
essa palavra você é usada apenas como
uma figura de expressão, sem o que não é
possível falar,
né? Mas eventualmente aí talvez seja
possível não falar sobre isso também. O
Buda não, Buda não fala sobre isso
assim, não diz você, mas ele vai dizer
dessa natural liberdade que surge, né?
Agora, eu acho que uma das chaves para
nós, que é o que nós estamos seguindo,
né? Uma das chaves paraa visão, pessoal,
é esse aspecto do corpo e da mente,
naturalmente, como nós estamos olhando,
sendo que o aspecto do corpo,
ah, se a gente usar esse processo da
bolha,
ele nos ajuda muito, porque nós vamos
perceber que a nossa que a bolha que tá
operando,
ela produz toda a sensação de existência
dentro do corpo. Eu preciso contemplar
isso.
Então, as sensações de viver dentro de
um corpo, elas vêm pelo automatismo do
movimento da energia dentro do corpo.
Quando a energia se movimenta dentro do
corpo, nós temos uma identidade com esse
movimento de energia e aquilo parece uma
uma natural existência. é tão natural
quanto a visão dos olhos e a as
o sentido das palavras que brotam junto
com os sons. É tudo completamente
natural. Nós temos uma conexão cármica
direto nisso. E essa conexão cármica que
vai brotando, ela dá um sentido de
escolha. E esse sentido de escolha
aponta a identidade.
Então, do mesmo modo, as energias
circulam por dentro de nós. Nós dizemos:
"Man, isso é a minha energia, isso é o
meu coração e sou eu."
Essa é uma boa razão para tu fazer as
yogas
todas, né? estudar os chakras, os
ventos. Se tiver dificuldade, precisa
fazer isso com todo cuidado. Se a pessoa
tiver uma capacidade de olhar, ela já vê
tudo isso como luminoso,
né? Ela passa batido,
mas se não tiver, a pessoa vai
desenvolvendo progressivamente a
capacidade de ver esses estados. Ela
cultiva os estados das energias
internas, ela vê aquilo, ela desloca de
um lado, desloca para outro lado, até
que ela percebe que existe uma liberdade
antes disso mesmo e que esses movimentos
eles são movimentos cármicos.
Como é que a pessoa vai perceber que são
movimentos cármicos? Esse é o ponto. Ela
vai perceber
porque ela vê que de acordo com a visão
da bolha, os movimentos são de um jeito
ou de outro.
É assim.
Se eu disser para vocês, por exemplo,
que hoje meio-dia e um pouco depois vai
vi uma super tempestade, a gente não vai
mais conseguir sair com o carro hoje,
isso muda alguma coisa?
Isso muda.
E também eu queria dizer para vocês que
a comida vai terminar,
não é assim? Então, os próximos três
dias nós vamos ter que comer uma vez por
dia só enquanto a gente espera que a
água baixa aqui para poder ir embora
assim. Então essa é a bolha.
Eu disse: "Olha, quem sair antes pode
comer antes. E você
assim né?
Mas
enfim, quando a bolha se estabelece, aí
nós temos
aflições, movimentos de energia
variados, aí tu muda a bolha, aquilo
desaparece.
Então o movimento de energia interno,
ele não é eu
não, mas tá fora do horário, tá vendo no
meio cedo, não é depois.
E aí
não é que não é que vai ver que é mes
>> outro exemplo. Não diz para vocês que
vai vir um sol agora da tarde, pessoal.
Aí em cima vocês resolvam aí. Nós
precisamos ir embora.
Eh, então aí nós percebemos que esse
movimento que é nosso,
sou eu, nós temos uma ligação muito
íntima, muito impossível de soltar dos
movimentos todos de energia.
E
tá pronto, já deu. O pessoal todo já
entendeu. Aí deixamos assim.
Então tem essa ligação muito íntima. Nós
precisamos desenraizar isso. A gente
precisa desenraizar isso com trocando de
bolhas e vendo as identidades surgindo.
Nós não somos isso.
E a gente precisa dessa desse choque de
reconhecer que aquilo que nós vemos é
são sempre objetos dentro de bolhas. Mas
agora eu preciso também reconhecer que
aquilo que eu sinto vivo pulsando dentro
de mim também é inseparável das bolhas.
Quando a gente olha isso pra mente
e olha pro corpo, a identidade vai ficar
onde? A identidade
ela não tem mais base, pessoal. Entende?
A identidade vai tentar se manter dentro
da loucura que brota pelas energias,
porque eu não sei olhar isso, mas quando
nós olhamos isso é a mesma coisa.
Aí eventualmente
a loucura desliza para dentro dos sete
fatores da iluminação,
que é o que nós vamos que nós começamos
e vamos até o fim.
Pessoal, todos esses fatores da
iluminação são maravilhosos,
que dão um trabalhão.
Então, um bico compreende, o fator da
iluminação da tensão plena está em mim.
E se o fator da iluminação da tensão
plena não estiver nele, ele compreende,
o fator da iluminação da tensão plena
não está em mim. E ele também compreende
como estimular o fator da iluminação da
tensão plena que não está estimulado e
como o fator da iluminação da tensão
plena que não está estimulado alcança a
sua plenitude através do
desenvolvimento. Então isso é a nossa
prática. Nós vamos fazer isso, só que a
gente não pode ficar preso nisso.
Aí, estando presente nele o fator da
iluminação da investigação dos
fenômenos, se eu olho pros fenômenos, eu
vejo não dualidade, eu vejo eh
luminosidade, eu olho todos esses
aspectos
e vejo também a mente que tá vendo isso,
né? Então, estando presente nele o fator
da iluminação da investigação dos
fenômenos,
ele diz: "O fator da iluminação da
investigação dos fenômenos está em mim.
Se o fator da iluminação da investigação
dos fenômenos não estiver presente nele,
ele compreende o fator da iluminação, da
investigação dos fenômenos não está em
mim." E ele também compreende como
estimular o fator da iluminação, da
investigação dos fenômenos. que não está
estimulado e como o fator da iluminação,
da investigação dos fenômenos
que está estimulado, então agora alcança
sua plenitude através do
desenvolvimento. É assim. Então, um por
um desses itens a gente tem que dizer
essa essas palavras todas. Aqui no texto
ele tá nos três pontinhos, mas a gente
precisa entender isso.
É assim. Aí nós
dos sete pontos da iluminação, dois já
foram. Quando eu chegar no sétimo
r, o céu se abre
e aí surge a energia,
fator da iluminação da energia. Super
importante, pessoal. Então vocês vêm
primeiro a gente podia voltar lá
chamata, né? Aí tá bem, chamada eu vou
introduzir como tensão plena. Então eu
entro com chamata e eu vou desenvolvendo
a tensão plena a partir da base de
chamata. Tá bem?
Aí eu vou desenvolver a visão. Eu
preciso investigação dos fenômenos. A
visão vai aparecer.
Quando a visão aparece, aí surge a
energia que tá escondida dentro da
delusão.
Por exemplo, as coisas delusivas elas
elas elas são um nó.
Esse nó, por vezes, é chamado mudra.
Então, é um nó.
Quando eu desato o nó, a energia
aparece.
Por que que é um nó? Porque não tem
objeto que não diga faça isso, mas não
faça aquilo tá dentro de uma bolha e ele
indica alguma coisa. Então eu tenho
sempre uma um um conjunto de restrições
naquilo.
Aí eu de repente eu libero. Liberar
significa que eu vejo aquilo fora da
bolha. Eu olho e vejo o aspecto real
daquilo. A energia se libera. Por quê?
Porque eu fiz a investigação dos
fenômenos. Aí eu a energia se libera.
Dessa energia liberada,
eu tenho a bemaventurança, que é
descrito como êxtase.
Então eu tenho a experiência de suca.
Se o açúcar tá ali, tudo bem. Se não tá,
eu vou treinar.
Havendo isso aí, não tem mais nada que
me produza intranquilidade, nada que me
produza flutuação e e
algum nível de medo. Então, eu tenho
tranquilidade. Por exemplo, se eu tiver
focado no mundo da não forma, eu tenho
uma agitação, tenho um nível de
agitação, mas aqui eu tenho
tranquilidade.
Quando a tranquilidade surge, a
concentração é natural.
Por quê? Porque os olhos pousam em
alguma coisa, a mente se posiciona seja
no que for e não tem nada que arraste o
perturbe. Então a concentração ela não é
o resultado de algo, mas ela ocorre.
E havendo isso, nós vamos chegar na
eanimidade. A equanimidade ela vai
culminar
na
mandala de Vajra,
aonde nós vamos reconhecer
aonimidade como
a natureza de todas as experiências.
Elas são não duais, vazias, luminosas e
assim. Então, a mandala vagora aparece
junto com a economidade. Aanimidade é a
qualidade da terra pura de canista.
Aí um bico chegando a isso, ele
compreende,
compreende a última, né? Aqui ele vai
descrever a última de forma completa. O
fator da iluminação da econanimidade
está em mim. Se o fator da iluminação da
eanimidade não estiver presente nele,
ele compreende o fator da iluminação da
economidade não está em mim. Ele também
compreende como estimular o fator da
iluminação da ecanimidade que não está
estimulado. E como o fator da iluminação
da economidade que não está estimulado
alcança sua plenitude através do
desenvolvimento.
A gente poderia dizer que todos esses
aspectos eles estão dentro da categoria
que Dud Rimpoch vai dizer numa frase
curta que nós vamos seguir o caminho de
Rigpa e só o caminho de Rigpa, porque
nós seguimos o caminho de olhar para
dentro e nós estamos desenvolvendo essa
capacidade de olhar para dentro e ver
que é o caminho de Rigba. E aí nós
atingimos a plenitude através desse
desenvolvimento.
E aí vem a frustração final. Quer dizer,
dessa forma ele permanece contemplando
os objetos mentais, pessoal. Objetos
mentais. Foi horrível isso. Com objetos
mentais internamente,
externamente e tanto interna quanto
externamente. E ele permanece
independente, sem nenhum apego a
qualquer coisa mundana.
Assim é como o beco permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais em relação aos sete
fatores da iluminação.
Então é isso aí. Ele segue. Aí vem as
quatro noves verdades. Aí nós entendemos
isso assim, pá.
Aí nós deslizamos para essa descrição
que eu tava fazendo. Ou seja, eu me dou
conta que se eu tiver fixado,
seja no que for, em verdades sutis que
sejam,
eu tenho,
eu caio dentro da perspectiva da
primeira das quatro nobres verdades,
porque eu tenho sofrimento inevitável.
Sim, o sofrimento ele é essencialmente a
vida. Então, se eu tiver cultivando
alguma coisa sutil, eu vou cultivar
aquela visão junto com a identidade que
surge junto. E eu não me livro da
intranquilidade, da aflição e do medo e
das várias coisas, porque tudo que é
construído produz inevitavelmente
sofrimento, uma vez que não tenho como
sustentar alguma coisa construída.
Então aqui um bico compreende.
Isso é sofrimento,
né? Ele começa assim. Então, novamente,
bicos, um bico permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais
agora em relação às quatro nobres
verdades.
E como um bico permanece contemplando os
objetos mentais como objetos mentais em
relação às quatro nobres verdades. Eu
acho isso super importante também,
pessoal, porque é assim, na visão
marhaiana e na visão de todos os ianas e
todas as apresentações que vêm
subsequentemente vão apresentando todos
os ntigs,
vocês vão ver as quatro noves verdades
como uma coisa assim pá. Isso aqui é o
início do início. Quatro noves verdades,
pá. Isso aqui não é nada, pessoal. As
quatro novas verdades, nós estamos
olhando como a raiz, ela ela tá
especificando o sofrimento que brota da
fixação dos estados mentais mais sutis.
Eu tô apontando aquilo como sofrimento.
Aquilo tá valendo até o fim.
É assim. Então eu entendo como é que o
sofrimento vem. Eu me fixo, eu produzo
terra em coisas muito sutis, como por
exemplo estados meditativos muito sutis.
Ele serve como terra e eles então quando
aquela terra é vista a pessoa não não
deixa de surgir porque tão pronto nós
vemos terra, nós somos alguma coisa que
tá vendo terra e nós surgimos ancorados
naquilo. Essa identidade surge. E a
visão de terra significa
o um elemento dentro de alivinana na
oitava consciência. Eu tô preso no
estado mental particular. Dso, surge, a
identidade, corresponde à sétima
consciência. E dessa sétima consciência
surge a sexta operando,
raciocinando,
né? É assim. Então o bico permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais em relação às quatro
noves verdades e como um bico permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais com
objetos mentais em relação às quatro
nobres verdades. Aqui um bico. Vocês
veem o que que é um bico, pessoal? Um
bico aqui nesse nível é um vidadara, é
um detentor da visão,
né? Pode ser. O bico é essencialmente
isso, é um videadra júnior ou um
videadra capaz de entrar nos vários
lugares. Então o Vidiadra que é capaz de
entrar nos vários lugares
é como do John Limpo. Ele tá sentado num
trono inexpugnável.
Então ele permanece contemplando os
objetos.
Ele compreende
como na verdade é isso. É o sofrimento.
Ele compreende como na verdade é isso. É
a origem do sofrimento. Pelu.
Ele compreende como na verdade é essa a
sensação do sofrimento.
Ele compreende como na verdade é. Esse é
o caminho que leva a sensação do
sofrimento. Qual é o caminho?
Sat, visão direta.
É assim, é ficar muito claro as quatro
afirmações. Dessa forma, ele permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais. Pessoal, é muito
estreito tu pensar que as pessoas
pensar assim, eu tô no meio do mundo, aí
eu tenho problemas, eu tenho isso, tenho
aquilo, fui demitido, aí eu tenho que
fazer esforço, tenho que respirar todo
dia, tenho que tomar banho, que isso é o
sofrimento, né? E agora que nós estamos,
nós vamos passar por chuva, vamos passar
por estrada ruim, nós estamos sempre com
sofrimento. Isso é muito estreito.
Sofrimento é alguma coisa sutil, é a
vida.
Aí vem o vem a visão, insite, que é a
parte
de
do que que a gente aprendeu. Enfim,
dessa forma ele permanece contemplando
os objetos mentais como objetos mentais.
internamente ou ele permanece
contemplando os objetos mentais como
objetos mentais externamente
ou ele permanece contemplando os objetos
mentais como objetos mentais tanto
interna quanto externamente.
Ou então ele permanece contemplando os
fenômenos que surgem nos objetos mentais
e eles e ele ou ele permanece
contemplando fenômenos que desaparecem.
Esse esse ponto é super importante
também porque a gente não chegou nem a
analisar isso, mas esses fenômenos
todos, tudo isso que eu tô treinando, aí
ele, por exemplo, ele vê isso tá
presente, isso não tá presente. Aí
aquilo que não tá presente faz surgir e
aquilo que que surge tu estabiliza.
Por quê? Porque é artificial, pessoal.
Então eu não posso me fixar. É simples,
é artificial.
Então ele permanece contemplando os
fenômenos que desaparecem,
os objetos mentais. Ele permanece
contemplando os ambos, os fenômenos que
surgem
como os fenômenos que desaparecem nos
objetos mentais. Portanto, não são
confiáveis.
Nós estamos focando o quê? Nós estamos
buscando a natureza que não flutua, que
já tá lá, que não é construída.
Ou então a atenção plena de que existem
objetos mentais
se estabelece somente na medida
necessária
para o conhecimento, senão não consigo
apontar aquilo ali. São objetos mentais
delusivos. Então digo que ali são
objetos mentais aí eu consigo olhar
dentro e dizer delusivos.
Então aquilo se estabelece somente na
medida necessária para o conhecimento e
para a continuidade da atenção plena.
E aí vem a frase mais assustadora. E ele
permanece independente.
É isso. Então ele vai descrever essa
natureza livre. Ele não entra e não
desenvolve fixação,
identidade. Não dá origem a identidade
dentro disso. Então ele permanece
independente, sem nenhum apego qualquer
coisa mundana. Então ele é capaz de
observar as aparências, mas ele não
gruda. Ele observa, mas ele não gruda.
Assim é como um bico permanece
contemplando os objetos como objetos
mentais.
É assim. Então o que que ele tá fazendo?
Ele tá praticando a a capacidade de
viver muitos diferentes mundos. que ele
entrou no mundo dos bicos que ficam
desenvolvendo sete fatores da iluminação
e ele se liber ele mostra como se
libertar disso, né?
Aí no final ele disse: "Se você entendeu
isso, que esse texto não sobre nada".
não diz isso.
Aí vem a conclusão. Bicos, qualquer um
que desenvolver esses quatro fundamentos
da atenção plena dessa maneira durante 7
anos, aí tem esse problema, 7 anos, um
dos dois resultados pode ser esperado ou
conhecimento supremo aqui e agora ou não
retorno, se ainda houver algum resíduo
de apego. Então havendo algum resíduo de
apego a estados mentais particulares,
surge o não retorno. O não retorno é
assim: nós surgimos dentro do mundo da
forma e da não forma. Não retorno ao
mundo do desejo.
Aí nós ressurgimos do mundo da forma e
da não forma. E dentro do mundo da forma
da não forma nós o intuímos o restante
do caminho. Nos liberamos pelo caminho
dos janas.
Sem falar em 7 anos, bicos.
Parece o Trump negociando.
Eu até gosto de vocês, né? A gente pode,
se você quiser telefonar para mim,
telefone aí,
sem falar em 7 anos, bicicos. Qualquer
um que desenvolver esses quatro
fundamentos da atenção plena dessa
maneira durante 6 anos.
5 anos, 4 anos, 3 anos, 2 anos, 1 ano.
Um de dois resultados pode ser esperado
ou conhecimento supremo aqui e agora ou
não retorno, se ainda houver algum
resíduo de apego.
Então, não é bom isso, pessoal. Nós já
estamos meio liberados do mundo do
desejo, né? Vai todo mundo pro mundo
da forma e da não forma.
Mas aí ele não parece uma negociação
assim, primeiro tu faz um bullying, tu
dá um não, agora 50%,
100%, 150% de tarifa.
Aí ele disse: "Não, não, 100%." e ficou
olhando 50%, 40%, 30%.
Não sei da onde é que o esse ser aí
puxou, mas eu acho que ele andou lendo
isso aqui.
Sem falar em um ano, bicicos.
qualquer um que desenvolver esses quatro
fundamentos da atenção plena dessa
maneira durante 7 meses, 6 meses,
5 meses, 4 meses, 3 meses. Bom, eu não
vou, eu não, eu não, não baixaria mais
do que isso. 3 meses. Mas aí o Buda tá
aí, meses, um mês, meio mês. Ah, não. Aí
já
um dos dois resultados pode esperado,
pode ser esperado ou conhecimento
supremo aqui e agora
ou o não retorno, se ainda houver algum
resíduo de apego.
Sem falar em meio mês, bico.
O banda tá um dia muito bom.
Não, isso não. Isso aí tem um erro de
tradução. Com certeza.
Sem falar em meio mês, bicos, qualquer
um que desenvolver esses quatro
fundamentos da atenção plena dessa
maneira durante 7 dias,
um de dois resultados pode ser esperado
ou o conhecimento supremo aqui e agora
ou o não retorno, se ainda houver algum
resíduo de apego.
Essa parte do não retorno, pessoal, a
gente pode deslizar para isso. E eu vou
explicar para vocês como é que a gente
faz para renascer no mundo da forma, da
não forma,
porque acho não é é uma coisa
intermediária assim, né?
E essencialmente nós temos que converter
tudo que surge para olhos, ouvidos,
nariz, língua e tato. E as sensações
internas das energias, converter tudo
isso para estados mentais.
Aí quando nós convertemos para estados
mentais, onde é que nós estamos? Nós
estamos num lugar que já não é
o lugar de olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua
e tato.
É um lugar aonde nós estamos passeando
por dentro dos estados mentais. Então
vamos supor que nós estamos aqui mesmo
nesse mundão aqui com olhos, ouvidos,
nariz, língua e tato. Quando vocês
sentirem que os impulsos que brotam
dentro eles não estão definidos
pelas aparências de olhos, ouvidos,
nariz, língua e tato, mas eles estão
definidos por estados sutis, aí nós já
estamos no mundo da forma e da não
forma. É assim.
E aí, marca? Não tem mais chance. Deu.
Na próxima vida é sem caminhonete, sem
painel solar. Aí deu,
mas ainda tem um apegozinho aos estados
mentais.
Assim, vem referência a isso que foi
dito bicos.
Esse é o caminho direto.
Você sabe o que que é caminho direto?
Caminho direto é assim, direto.
Por quê? Porque nós estamos olhando as
várias aparências e estão purificando as
aparências. Estamos vendo aquilo como é
que é e estamos ganhando independência.
Então não preciso nem falar de
vacuidade, pessoal. Ele tá falando de
independência.
O caminho da vacuidade, ele começa
quando eu tô fixado ao aspecto dual.
Aí eu preciso trabalhar longamente para
ver que aquilo não é aquilo naquilo
mesmo. Leva um tempo. Aí lá pelas tantas
tu vê a bolha, onde como é que aquilo
surge, aí tu vê que existe uma não
dualidade. Aí nós vamos avançando.
Mas aqui o Buda tá transmitindo guru
yoga. Ou seja, pela visão tu já percebe
a independência em relação à aqueles
aspectos.
Então esse é o caminho direto para a
purificação dos seres, para superar a
tristeza e lamentação,
para o desaparecimento da dor e da
angústia, para alcançar o caminho
verdadeiro
para a realização de Nibana. Então,
nibana vai ser descrito como o como se
fosse o ambiente lúcido de onde tudo
isso é visto. Isso é Nibana. Onde isso é
visto é Nibana. Isso é os quatro
fundamentos da tensão plena. Isso foi
que o abençoado disse. Os bicos ficaram
satisfeitos e contentes com as palavras
do abençoado.
Isso, essa observação,
não sei de onde é que vem isso, porque
aqui não não tem nada para ficar nem
feliz, nem contente. Não tem nada para
ver. Tem que praticar, pessoal. Aí eles
viram isso e praticaram ou só ficaram
felizes contentes, perguntaram que mais
agora abençoado? Que é o que eles de
modo geral faziam assim.
esse cara satisfeitos e contentes com as
palavras abençoado.
Tudo bem,
por isso que não dá certo.
Eu vou aproveitar isso, né? Eu acho
mesmo, pessoal, que o que acontece é
assim que lembrar isso.
Obrigado.
Então é assim, as pessoas pega esse
ensinamento,
aí nós vamos praticando, nós vamos
praticando aí
nós vamos encontrando dificuldades,
então nós vamos tomando parte do
ensinamento que é o início.
Aí nós temos dificuldade naquilo, a
gente pega o início do início e vai
pegando. Daqui a pouco nós estamos só no
início do início do início.
que as pessoas que galgam isso e vão,
elas não estão na sustentação do grupo
que mantém a prática disso. Vocês
entendem o problema?
Quem fica são os que não atingiram a
realização. Vocês entendem?
É assim. Então, a estrutura envelhece.
Aí quando a estrutura envelhece, o
ensinamento ele fica simples e ele fica
fixado em alguma coisa que, enfim, as
pessoas ali estão podendo praticar, que
eu acho super bom,
super bom. Enfim, aquilo precisa ser
praticado. Agora, quem vem depois e quer
ir até o final, de repente vai encontrar
uma barreira que eles vão dizer: "Não,
aqui não, isso aqui a gente não atinge
iluminação." Não é assim. Você vai ter
que praticar muito longo, muito tempo.
Eles vão botando coisas assim
impossíveis.
Tu não tem visão. Eles não te eles não,
eles abandonam a visão
e te empurram pro mundo da pra forma.
Eles te empurram pro caminho. Eles são
especialistas no caminho.
Eles não são especialistas na visão.
Então eles vão dizer: "Não, não, vamos
parar. Senta e faz tal coisa. Agora faz
tal outra coisa e agora faz tal outra
coisa. ele te manter fazendo.
Aí tem aqueles que vêm, porque eles já
tinham resolvido a coisa mais ou menos
na outra vida, eles te dão uma olhada
assim, dizem: "Pá, por aqui eu não tenho
como".
Aí vai.
E o açanga foi um desses.
Aí ele viu, pá, por aí não tem como.
Vocês vão encontrar muitos grandes
praticantes, detentores de visão, etc.,
que andaram por dentro dos mosteiros e
riscaram,
né? A Morre Poché, Patrinha Poché. E tem
uma lista, esses mestres eles riscaram,
eles ficaram por ali,
passaram as vergonhas que passam dentro
das estruturas, né?
Como Chantidava, por exemplo, né?
Aí eles estão ali dentro. Aí tem uma
comunidade de seres fixados em coisas.
Mas é onde tá o ensinamento. Aí eles têm
que vencer aquilo. Eles têm não só que
acessar o ensinamento, mas eles tem que
vencer o entorno que obstaculiza.
Esse entorno ele vem se estruturando a
partir dos que ficam para trás e não dos
que vão paraa frente, entende? Aí os que
vão paraa frente eles começam a rezar
pela pelos ensinamentos que vem depois
do Buda Sequemunha. Aí a Sega vai pedir
paraa Maitreia aparecer. Aí quando
aparece, surge uma raina.
Uma raiana pula por cima dessa estrutura
e considera essa estrutura inferior.
Mas não porque ela seja inferior, ela
não é. É que a forma de praticar isso,
ela envelheceu.
Depois vai acontecer o mesmo com
Maríano. O Marano começa a envelhecer,
ele começa a virar a compaixão comum.
A compaixão extraordinária, ela vai
desaparecendo.
Compaixão extraordinária é o fim de aí,
ela vai desaparecendo. Aí nós começamos
a ficar praticando o primeiro dos 10
boomes. Se der, nessa vida, eu acho que
não atinge o primeiro boom. Então,
abandona a noção de visão,
né? Vocês também vão observar assim,
mesmo que os ensinamentos
sejam visão, sejam prágina paramita, né?
que deu um trabalhão para para fazer
surgir no reino humano o prajna
paramita.
Ainda que isso esteja ali, as pessoas
não estudam,
né? Então vocês vão ver,
lamentavelmente,
né? Vocês vão ver mosteiros, eles até
recitam,
recitam todo dia, mas eles não
aprofundam aquilo. Não aprofundam porque
aquilo já não é o ponto. O ponto agora é
assim, nós temos que recitar todo dia,
manter. Isso é o nosso treinamento.
Então a gente abandona a visão e adota
a ah o caminho. Então a gente toma
refúgio no caminho e não na visão. E aí
nós vamos indo
dentro do disso aí vem a visão
extraordinária, vem a visão vajaraiana,
a visão vajera que tá vendo vacuidade e
luminosidade em tudo. Aí suj as
deidades, elas convergem, convertem
todas as deidades,
as deidades do ambiente e todas as
fontes de refúgio são todas converg,
todas vão convergindo para deidades que
são a manifestação do Buda primordial.
E aí eu fico recitando mantras,
fazendo oferendas,
montando ambientes e eu posso
simplesmente não compreender isso.
Aí eu perco a visão também, eu substituo
a visão pela forma, né? Eu acho a forma
vajaiana das deidades completamente
maravilhosa,
né? Eu fico feliz de ver que os sons
eles magnetizam as pessoas, as imagens
magnetizam o aspecto teatral, ele
magnetiza
e as deidades delas em si mesmo ao serem
vistas, elas são vistas. De fato, as
pessoas podem não ver, mas elas são
vistas.
A a aparência da deidade produz uma
experiência interna pessoa que a própria
deidade, a manifestação daidade surge
instantaneamente. Então, por exemplo, se
vocês vem aatara
com uma aparência compassiva ou com aim
com uma aparência compassiva,
surge um movimento de energia
correspondente a isso que eu tô vendo.
Então a deidade começa a surgir. Se eu
olhar, por exemplo, paraa dor de drolo
com uma aparência assim meio de fogo, eu
digo: "Pã, mas o que que é isso?" Então,
surge uma um nível de inquietude
que também é completamente natural. Por
quê? Porque Dog Dor tá apresentando
Praina Paramita para vocês. Ele tem numa
mão Praina Paramita e a aparência dele é
uma intranquilidade que aquilo vai te
trazer, porque tu não tá com vontade
nenhuma de ver a vacuidade das coisas.
Então, Doredrolo, se vocês olham com um
olho verdadeiro, não tem fogo, tem
apenas o Buda sentado calmo. O Buda
sentado calmo falando prágina paranita
te dá uma aparência de fogo e
destruição, fogo apocalíptico e
destruição, porque é essencialmente
isso, né? Mas eu tô apegado ao mundo,
apegado a uma porção de coisas. Então eu
olho assim, né? Então, as oito
manifestações de Guruim Poch, elas têm
aparências diferentes porque elas se
manifestam com diferentes regiões de
apego. Então são os as oito deidades, as
oito bodsátuas que vão surgir.
E aí nós vamos rezar, né? Trupeguro,
santendando peridan
são os oito que surgem. Aí nós estamos
entendendo isso. Só que a gente tá
entendendo, mas não tá entendendo isso.
Isso aqui virou um ritual.
Aí
aí todo esse ensinamento culmina na
natural perfeição
que já tá em todas as coisas.
Assim. Aí vem o ensinamento mais inxuto
que vai retirar essas várias formas.
uma por uma das deidades com viage para
Samanta Badra.
As deidades todas como guru em pochê,
oito manifestações,
mas guru em pochê, o que que é? Qual das
oito? Guru pochê é natureza livre das
próprias manifestações.
Ele é a Samanta Badra,
ele é o Buda, ele é o espaço amplo,
lúcido.
É assim.
Então eu acho isso muito comovente, que
de tanto em tanto até na visão,
na visão do budismo, os budas vêm
sucessivamente. Eles estão lá em Tuchita
aguardando.
Aí eles vem que a coisa complicou, eles
aparecem.
Por isso que Maitreia foi invocado, por
isso surge uma raiana.
Mas
na linhagem níma, especialmente no
gordismo tibetano, vai surgir a noção
dos tertons, né, que eu acho que é coisa
maravilhosa e muito real, né, que também
dialoga perfeitamente com a visão do
Buda, com a visão mahiana,
com o sutra do lotos, sutra avatanaca,
que é a noção de que existe muitos
mundos, cada mundo regido por um tipo de
sabedoria que dissol solve a delusão
correspondente à aquele mundo. E tudo
isso é visto pelo Buda primordial, que
vê essa multiplicidade
de mundos, que é o Trichilha Cosmos. E o
Buda vê não só o Trichilha Cosmos
inteiro com essa multiplicidade, mas ele
vê
infinitos trichilha cosmos, que é uma
coisa assim meio
assustadora.
E aí a gente vê que a gente tem um
apegozinho ao nosso Trichilha Cosmos.
Aí o Buda vai falar do Trichilha Cosmos
que tá além, que não pode ser visto,
portanto, porque nós estamos dentro de
um Trichilha Cosmos. A gente vê um
Trichilha Cómos, a gente não vê os
outros.
Essa parte eu não gostei, mas enfim. O
Buda vê
assim. Então ele vê mundos que não se
conectam, mundos que surgem de outro
jeito.
É assim. Então maravilhoso isso, assim,
né? E aí o o dentro da dessa transmissão
que vem através especialmente da natural
perfeição, aí vai surgir a noção de guru
em pochê, que tem essa intenção
iluminada de clarificar,
iluminar tudo em todas as direções. Isso
tá em pressa, em todas as aparências.
Vocês vão ver as preces dentro do das
nossas sadanas. Se vocês olharem com
cuidado, vocês vão ver isso, tá descrito
lá dentro.
E
e aí nós temos
ah os tertons, ou seja, de tanto em
tanto vão surgindo emanações de
gruhimpoch
que vão resolvendo aquilo e tornam
aquilo vivo. Por exemplo, do rimpch, né?
Então, do pochê é uma emanação.
Naturalmente ele já é uma continuidade
de do John Limpa, né, que é uma emanação
fulminante né folgorante
de guru poché,
né? Então isso é muito maravilhoso,
muito especial assim a gente reconhecer
esse aspecto, né? Então o a essas
emanações elas reativam a visão. Então
elas tão no nível da visão. Aquilo
aparece a visão de novo.
Então a gente tá nesse tempo muito
extraordinário, né? assim,
eu acho que a gente tem um um desafio
eh um desafio um pouco assustador, que é
eh que que é um pouco o próprio fogo de
e de
Dor Drolo, né? O fogo de Dorrolo tá no
olhar de de Dion Limpa, no olhar de Dion
Rimpoché, no olhar de Long Champa e de
todos os mestres que vão trazendo essas
visões de modo vivo, né?
Esse fogo, ele ele é um pouco assustador
porque ele elimina
muitas coisas que são caras para nós.
Por exemplo, a gente pergunta: "Bom, e
qual é então o sentido da existência?
Para onde que eu tô indo?" A gente quer
ter uma sensação de que a gente tá indo
para algum lugar quentinho, confortável,
verdadeiro, onde a gente possa ficar lá.
E aí tem os coletores solares, tem as
bateria funcionando, né? Na terra pura a
bateria não estraga e e tudo funciona
direito assim, né? A gente quer alguma
coisa direita assim, mas aí pronto, aí
já não tem isso. Aí como é que fica? Eu
não sei como é que fica, não gostei
disso.
Será que tem alguma alternativa? Me
falem aí, porque não tô gostando dessa
história, né? Então nós temos isso aí. A
visão ela é diferente, né? Eu penso,
bom, pelo menos em chamata eu vou me
equilibrar, chamata também não vai
resolver.
Aí todos os janas, nenhum deles, todos
os janas, pessoal, tem nome em
sânscrito, tem a descrição de como é que
tu entra naquele estado meditativo,
tem a realização, tem os sinais de
realização de um por um dos gênos. Tudo,
eu ia dizer fake, não é fake, aquilo é
um tudo um jana, ou seja, um estado
particular
que tem início, meio e fim.
É, né? Ainda assim, nós
progressivamente né paulatinamente
vamos ganhar
uma
uma independência. Então, é o que nós
vamos ganhar. É uma independência. Essa
independência inclui independência de
nós mesmos, de tudo aquilo que a gente
pensar que nós somos, de tudo aquilo que
parece que o mundo é de todos os sinais
que brotam brilhando dentro do nosso
coração,
né? É assim, nós vamos nos livrar disso
tudo, mas nós temos uma conexão
longínqua com isso, né? Nós temos
muitos, muitas alianças que a gente fez
ao longo dos caminhos. né? Então, a
gente não tá muito disposto a abandonar
isso. Meu coração tem sido um bom
conselheiro por muito tempo. Quando ele
brilha, eu sigo. Quando ele não brilha,
eu não sigo. A gente tem essa aliança há
muito tempo. E agora eu faço, o que que
eu faço? Deixa o coração ali. Fique aí
agora. Eu tô indo. Tchau. Coração.
Coração. Não, não, eu vou junto.
Assim, aí já não sei o que é que eu
faço. E a minha identidade, ela tem sido
tão boa. Eu eu usei ela como chave para
entrar em vários lugares. E agora, né? E
o meu violão, eu levo ou não levo? O
violão tá ficando tão triste. Eu tô
indo.
E aí, Tatá? Vou o violão, nós queremos
garantir, o violão tem que ir junto.
Sim. Aí tem esse ponto. Aí nós estamos
cheios de coisas quentinhas, agradáveis,
cor de derrosa de várias cores, né? E a
gente, o que que nós vamos fazer,
pessoal?
Eu acho melhor essa parte final. A gente
corta.
Essa coisa de independência é muito
guariana.
É isso, Cão.
Sagitariano também. É Raul.
Então aí,
bom, aí terminou, né? Mas tem um aqui,
tem alguns sutras, por exemplo, caiata
sati.
Sat.
Então onde vocês vem s sem sem sem sem
apego nenhum, né? Então caia é corpo,
né?
Gata é os versos. Então caia gata suta.
Então suta, que são os versos sobre o
corpo. Então ele vai mais profundamente
no aspecto corpo. Então ele vai
introduzir mais detalhes sobre o aspecto
do corpo.
Há também o marah satpatana. Marra é
grande. Então tem o Sati Patana e tem o
Marra Satipatana que ele é um pouco mais
longo, mais detalhado, mas é
essencialmente isso. Mas o Marra
Satipatana, ele vai trabalhar mais as
quatro nobres verdades,
né? Aí tem o Anapanassat suta, que
começa com essa experiência da própria
meditação com a respiração, né? Então eu
tomo a estabilização da medita da
respiração como uma um como um corrimão
a partir do qual eu começo a praticar as
outras coisas.
E aí tem o Janas Suta e outros sutras
que tratam do Janas.
Então tem o caminho todo do Janas todo
descrito, né? Tem os ensinamentos do
Nepola Raula aqui no Brasil que foi
publicado em português, aonde ele traz
todos os janas e vai explicando isso. De
qualquer modo, de é quase sempre os
ensinamentos Teravada com respeito aos
Janas, eles colocam os janas como
desejáveis,
como como degraus de uma escada. E eu
vou treinando sobre aquilo, né? É assim,
os ensinamentos de Budagocha,
eles são os ensinamentos que são
considerados o topo da dos ensinamentos
davada. E eu acho que são realmente e
eles são ensinamentos tão sutis
e de SAT que eu não me animei ainda a
trazer, porque é alguma coisa, se aqui é
difícil de falar, porque se a gente não
pratica essas palavras, elas voam, não
consegue segurar essas palavras.
O os ensinamentos do Visu de Maga de
Budagoxa,
eles se não praticados simplesmente não
entra naquilo.
E nós precisamos praticar e aí nós vamos
dando sentido às palavras
correspondentes
com base naquele naquelas palavras que
brotam de dentro da própria meditação.
Se eu não meditar, aquelas palavras não
ganham sentido.
É como, por exemplo, se eu explicar como
é que faz um pão pra gente que não sabe
o que que é farinha, o que que é sal, o
que que é óleo. Aí tu diz: "Pegue
farinha". A pessoa farinha seria o quê,
né? É assim. Então o viso de mago é
assim. Então ele diz: "Pegue farinha".
Mas viso de farinha como? Que que você
quer dizer com isso? Né? Sendo ainda que
todas essas palavras elas estão todas em
palhe.
Então, se a gente não entender os
ingredientes, tu não entende a receita.
Então, para entender os ingredientes, tu
tem que ter familiaridade com os
aspectos que vão ser nomeados,
sendo que esses aspectos que vão ser
nomeados, eles surgem como experiências
dentro da própria meditação.
Para vocês terem uma ideia, um dos dos
aspectos que é trabalhado é justamente
os casinas,
que vocês não vão encontrar essa palavra
em lugar nenhum, a não ser no visu de
maga. Eu
vou dar gosto. E aquilo é super
importante.
Vocês só vão encontrar uma conexão dos
casinas quando tiverem lá em lá na
estudando os textos da natural
perfeição. E os casinos aparecem sem
serem nomeados como tal, mas eles
aparecem.
É mais ou menos assim. As cores, elas
são manifestação direta da natureza
livre e luminosa da mente.
E assim você vai olhando isso e são os
casinas.
Quando nós olhamos as cores,
eu não tô vendo as cores, eu tô vendo
casinas posições eh posições
luminosas da minha mente que produzem
aquela experiência. Isso já é a
manifestação direta da luminosidade.
Se eu olhar em volta, em vez de eu ficar
vendo árvores, vendo céu, vendo coisas,
eu tô vendo as cores e elas são não
duais com minha própria mente.
Todos os mundos são
surgidos desse modo. Aí eu estudo os
múltiplos casinas que existem.
Entre os casinas tá o elemento terra,
elemento água, elemento fogo. Aí eu vejo
que meu olho tá vestido dos casinas e
por isso as coisas aparecem, mas eu vejo
os casinos como uma manifestação direta,
luminosa da própria mente.
Assim, então o bis de maga vai trabalhar
essa direção. Então, a o Viso de Maga
ele é resultado
de centenas de anos de prática de
dos bicos. Eles vão vendo, vendo, vendo
e aquilo tá tudo escrito. Então o o
Budagocha,
ele escreveu isso
depois de percorrer muitos diferentes
centros onde já não havia muitos
praticantes.
O budismo tava em
dissolução dentro da Índia por vários
tipos de guerras e perseguições. Os
praticantes estavam morrendo.
E ele teve esse cuidado, ele percorreu
esses lugares todos coletando essas
informações, né? Eu acho isso muito
comovente.
Aliás, eu vou fazer um aqui. Não não não
vem não não vai melhorar a nossa
reflexão aqui, mas eu não queria deixar
de mencionar isso também, porque tem uma
outra coisa se apagando,
que é o conhecimento dos guaranis,
dos indígenas guaranês. E o Cá Verá,
porque ele tem essa capacidade, ele
também percorreu muitos diferentes
lugares e coletou as informações dos
velhos
antes que os velhos morressem.
E ele publicou isso.
Só que isso também desaparece. A própria
publicação desaparece, mas é muito
sutil. O Cacaverá conhece em detalhe
todo esse mundo sutil dos guaranês.
E o mundo sutil dos guaranês é muito
profundo,
porque ele obteve o ensinamento que eles
só eles eles só vão contando oralmente.
Então só alguns que vão ouvir, porque se
a pessoa não tá naquele lugar não ouve.
Mas o Kaká ele foi nos vários lugares,
ele podia ouvir, eles falaram para ele,
entende? Ele fez essa traição, quer
dizer, essa essa coleta.
E o o Budag fez isso também. Então, isso
resultou no viso de Maga. Aí se diz que
quando o o Budago escreveu aquilo,
ah, ele escreveu e aí ele se recolheu.
Quando ele fechou os olhos, aí Indra
veio e roubou os textos.
Aí quando ele voltou, ué, que deu os
textos.
Aí ele escreveu tudo de novo.
Aí quando ele fechou os olhos,
Indra foi lá e roubou de novo.
Aí ele foi lá e escreveu tudo de novo.
Aí ainda trouxe os dois textos. Aí
ficaram os três. Então tem uma imagem
deles comparando as três versões. As
três versões são idênticas.
É assim. Então esse é um ponto. Ou seja,
quem é aqui ditou as três versões?
Samanta Badra, o Buda primordial. Ali
não tá dito, mas é claro. É isso.
Quem acreditou aquilo?
Que como é que é? Tudo vem, tudo vai,
como é que é?
É isso aí. Tem aquilo que permanece, né?
Aquilo que permanece. Isso foi quem
escreveu viso de magre.
A grande abertura assim, não é o karma
como eu tava pensando ontem.
Assim é grande.
Pode ser, né? Mas é muito bonito.
Pessoal, nós estamos nesse mundo. Esse é
o mundo que nós estamos.
É assim. Aí vocês olhem aqui qual é o
mundo que nós estamos. Abram os jornais,
abrem a internet aí. É um mundo que tá
todo mundo se matando, mas
pela pela
verdade do prágam pela verdade da
interdependência e não dualidade, pela
verdade da natureza livre da mente, nós
podemos construir mundos como esses e
nós atravessamos a loucura no meio desse
barco. Isso são as terras puras. É
assim. Aí nós podemos construir ou não
podemos? Podemos aí tá ali o templo
perguntar como é que a gente construiu.
A gente não construiu de uma forma
séria. Eu preciso confessar, pessoal,
não foi de uma forma séria. Uma forma
séria é assim, tu primeiro faz o
projeto, depois faz o orçamento, aí tu
capta os recursos, contrata o empréstimo
e constrói. Pois não foi. É assim, é
tudo por milagre. Diz Gru Pochê, um
milagre, por favor. Aí e não é que agora
surgiu um milagre bem recente, né? Eu
queria, aliás, agradecer todos veio
todos os seres que manifestaram junto
esse milagre por interdependência,
né? A gente não tava sabendo como é que
a gente ia fazer a instalação elétrica.
Problema aqui, né?
e
também o peso e também as várias coisas
que estão ainda faltando. E
aí não é que as pessoas fizeram muitas
doações nos últimos dois dias e assim e
vai sobrar até por uma festa que a
gente, quer dizer, nessa parte da festa
a gente não vai contar, né?
Não, na verdade você sabe, até eh obra
de igreja não termina nunca.
Nós estamos sempre na campanha.
Não, não. Agora a gente vai poder fazer
alguma coisa mais. Que que a gente vai
fazer?
Então, agora vai ver instalação elétrica
que a gente ganhou a mão de obra,
pessoal. Eu não vou citar assim, mas foi
maravilhosa essa mão de obra. Tinha um
orçamento que era era assim pesado, né?
Aí tinha um outro orçamento menor, mas
agora nós conseguimos um uma pessoa com
grande experiência internacional, né,
que vai resolver a nossa instalação
elétrica, que é isso, né?
E então a instalação elétrica, em
princípio tá OK, né? E aí que mais?
A parte hidrossanitária, porque enfim,
você sabe, karma é karma, né? Depois que
a gente aperta o botão, a gente tem que
saber o que que vai acontecer, né?
Então nós precisamos,
isso vai ser possível fazer também.
E o material do açoalho também vai ser
possível, pessoal. É assim. Então nós
estamos nesse ponto, né? E esse
assoalho, eu acho que vai ficar super
lindo assim, né? Super lindo, porque é
um o templo é octogonal, então no centro
vai ter um octógono, porque vocês
imaginem as madeiras tudo convergindo,
vai ficar tudo fininho no fim, né? Então
nós vamos fazer aquilo convergir para um
octógono que vai ser trabalhado,
esculpido.
Então vai ter uma flor de lottos, eu
acho. Assim, eu tava querendo botar dor
de drolo ali
assim, mas nós vamos fazer uma coisa
mais, nós temos que enganar as pessoas,
fazer uma coisa bem suave assim, uma
flor de lotas.
Também não fica bom botar dorador,
depois pisar por cima de dorador. Não é
interessante. Agora uma flor de lotos
acho que fica bem porque, enfim, todos
nós estamos sobre uma flor de lótus, né?
Então aquela flor de lótes tá assim na
base, o tempo inteiro flutua junto com a
flor de lotos, né? Tudo bem, né?
assim, mas a gente teve um pequeno
percalço porque a artista experiente que
vai fazer isso teve
que a mãe da da And, né? Não fica bonito
isso? A And construindo ali, a mamãe vai
lá, faz a flor de loto, fica bom, não
fica? Eu acho que fica bom, né? Vai
ficar legal assim. Então a tua mamãe tem
80 e
88, quase 89. Uma mulher de quase 89 vai
fazer isso. Não é bom isso, pessoal. Eu
acho maravilhoso. Eu acho muito
maravilhoso,
né? É assim, então a gente sempre vai
poder dizer isso, né? É assim,
maravilhoso.
Então, a gente vai ter essa parte
central assim.
E então agora tá faltando a mão de obra
para execução do aoalho. É um pouco
isso, né? E depois ainda tem as
pinturas, né? Mas aí nós vamos indo. A
gente pensa assim,
nós estamos operando de uma forma
virginiana capricorniana
ou não?
Isso aqui é, nós estamos seguindo um uma
abordagem capricorniana
sutil assim do céu.
Então, as portas elas já foram doadas.
Nós não temos as portas ainda, mas vai
ter a colocação das portas. É uma coisa
simples, né? Tem as portas todas em
madeira, super bonito aquilo também.
Depois tem as pinturas, tem o altar, mas
essa parte ela vai andar assim, uma vez
que a gente tem o açoalho, a gente vai
já vai fazendo as atividades, que eu
espero que seja em janeiro, né? A gente
tenha isso. Eu acho bom construir umas
terras puras, vocês não acham? Pessoal,
eu gosto disso. Por quê? Porque isso em
si mesmo já é um desafio, entende?
É um desafio. El uma demonstração de que
o mundo não precisa ser pensado como
guerra, como loucura, como como essa
essa perda de significados que a gente
vê por todo lado. Não precisa.
A gente pode construir boas coisas aqui.
Depois nós vamos pensar nas pinturas, o
que que nós vamos colocar ali. Aquilo é
super bonitas. Nós vamos andando.
Eu espero que aqui vai se consolidando
como esse lugar dos bicos, né? Se a
gente disseradaras, aí fica meio
os bicos
como
não, isso eu já não sei. Isso é os becos
assim né?
Aí tem
os bicos,
aliás são mais numerosos do que os
bicos, né? Que tem esse pequeno
problema né?
Não, mas quando diz os bicos vale para
todos, né? Assim.
E então esse é o ponto, né? Eu acho
muito raro, muito precioso, muito
maravilhoso se a gente pode manter e
pode viver desse modo, né? E até mesmo o
aspecto sutil é que mantém os lugares.
Qual é o aspecto? Como manter esse
lugar? Praticando. É só isso. Não
precisa nada, pessoal, nada heróico. Nós
vamos praticando. Os méritos são
suficientes para isso seguir. É assim.
Nice.
Então nós vamos fazer dedicação.
Mas tem uma pergunta aqui do Ban ou pode
falar.
Não liberaram ainda o microfone dele.
>> Agora deu.
>> Agoraama,
pergunta é é bem simples, bem curta. Eh,
parece que
mesmo quando ele fala que o Tá dando
para ouvir bem.
Dá, dá, tá dando para ouvir assim
>> mesmo quando ele, o Buda fala aqui que o
bico se mantém independente, né?
>> Aham.
>> É como se ainda tivesse um bico
independente de do objeto mental,
independente do corpo, independente da
mente,
>> independente das sensações, ainda
tivesse uma um sutil identidade por trás
ainda.
>> É isso mesmo.
>> É isso mesmo. Não tem como escapar
disso, né? É que tu não tem como falar
se tu não falar, né?
É assim,
>> é só isso mesmo.
>> A gente fala, tira as palavras depois.
Sim.
Então, que os méritos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos. Que o Mestre
Universal da Paz e da Compaixão, Sua
Santidade da Lailama, juntamente com
todos os mestres de todas as tradições
que veiculam essa mensagem, tenho longa
vida. que todos estejam a salvo de gerar
pensamentos negativos, o obstáculo mais
destrutivo, que esses pensamentos nunca
surjam nossa mente e que todos os seres
também estejam livres de pensamentos
negativos ao longo de minhas muitas
vidas e até este momento, todas as
virtudes que t alcançado,
inclusive os méritos gerados por esta
prática e todas as que vieram para
conseguir.
Ofereço para o bem-estar dos seres
sencientes.
Posso a doença, guerra, fome e
sofrimento diminuir para todos os seres,
enquanto sua sabedoria e compaixão
aumentam nesta em vidas futuras. possa
eu claramente perceber todas as
experiências
substanciais quanto tecido do sonho
durante a noite e imediatamente
despertar para perceber a manifestação
de sabedoria pura no surgir de cada
fenômeno. possa eu rapidamente alcançar
a iluminação para trabalhar sem cessar
pela liberação de todos os seres budas e
bodissávas em conjunto, seja qual for a
sua motivação, sua ação benéfica e
preces auspiciosas,
seja qual for a sua onciência,
realizações e poderes benévolos. E seja
qual for a sua imensa sabedoria,
que igualmente venho para beneficiar os
seres, rogo para que possa alcançar as
mesmas qualidades. Nesse exato momento
possam nem mesmo doença, fome, guerra e
sofrimento ser ouvidos pelas pessoas,
nações da terra, mas possam sim sua
conduta moral, mérito, riqueza e
prosperidade crescer e possam a suprema
bem-aventurança e bem-estar sempre
surgir para elas.
Eu
queria ainda lembrar assim,
eu acho que uma das características das
terras puras é o fato de que não deveria
ter muros em volta.
né? Esse eu considero assim, se vocês
olharem na Landa, eu também não quero
criticar nada porque eu não sou de
criticar, mas então dito isso aí eu
posso
assim na Landa, pessoal tinha grandes
muros.
Como é que um mosteiro vai ter grandes
muros?
Se o ensinamento ali é para beneficiar
todos os seres?
Sim.
Então os centros não deveriam ter
grandes muros, né? Mas se a gente não
tem grandes muros, as terras puras se
mantém ou não se mantém?
Então eu acho super importante entender
que, por exemplo, o caminho do meio tá
numa zona super,
vamos dizer, desafiadora,
né?
Nós estamos a 300 m com o castelinho,
mas nós estamos
sem muros.
A Dionia é capaz de manter o trabalho
dela dentro do castelinho, capaz de
manter o altar dela beneficiando as
crianças num lugar
muito perigoso.
Ela tá numa rua muito perigosa dentro
daquele lugar e ela mantém a terra pura.
Então, as terras puras, pessoal, elas
existem, elas se mantém por si,
né?
As as barreiras
e a se nós começarmos a olhar assim,
vocês quiserem ver o que que é a
decadência, é o surgimento dos muros.
A decadência é assim, nós temos uma
qualidade que se distingue do entorno e
o entorno tá perdido. Nós precisamos nos
proteger porque, enfim, é assim. Quando
a gente pensar assim,
não há diferença. Nós estamos no mundo
para
nós vamos aprender com todas as
aparências que surgirem.
Esse é o ponto. Assim,
se vocês olharem a os relatos históricos
da destruição de Nalanda, elas vêm eh
esses esses os povos que eles vêm do
turco menistão, hoje é descrito assim,
eles não são os turcos turcos, como a
gente colocaria na Turquia, em Ancara,
etc., né? Mas eles são povos que geraram
os turcos que tão na nessa região, mas
eles vêm de outras regiões. Eles são
primos dos mongóis também, né? Eles
viviam naquelas grandes planías. Então
eles invadiram a Índia e foram saqueando
aquilo tudo, né? Aí quando eles viram
aqueles muros todos, eles pensaram:
"Isso é uma fortaleza". Eles atacaram,
atacaram várias vezes. Aí eles viram que
eles podiam saquear.
Eles foram saqueando e matando
assim.
Então foi horrível aquilo. A Landa foi
destruída três vezes, foi reconstruída
três vezes. Aí foi destruída a quarta
vez não foi mais reconstruída.
Aí se conta que as pessoas se levantaram
dali, os que sobraram, né, que eu sempre
sobram os que estão viajando.
Aí eles voltam e encontram aquilo. Então
eles tinham um intercâmbio em muitas
direções. Então eles voltam, eles
reconstró aí depois reconstró. Aí eles
se deram conta, não, nós vamos para
essas outras regiões, vamos ficar por
lá, a gente não vai voltar
assim. Então isso também ajudou a
expandir o budismo, fim de Nalanda,
assim, né? Muito comovente,
mas eu acho importante a gente entender
esses aspectos assim, né?
Eh,
eu também queria agradecer a todos que
contribuíram aqui pra gente chegar nesse
ponto, né? Eu não tenho aqui a lista, eu
até bom, sabe? É melhor não dizer nome
de ninguém. Todo mundo sabe quem ajudou.
É muito bom assim, a gente agradece e
reconhece essa interdependência, né?
Assim, as pessoas colocaram seus
corações, as suas formas e o templo
chegou milagrosamente nesse ponto assim,
né?
Assim. Então isso vai seguir produzindo
benefício pros seres pelo tempo que que
for. E e esse tempo ele vai depender
especialmente
não dos muros ou da especialidade ou da
diferença que a gente criar em relação
aos seres, mas da nossa capacidade de
fazer prática e reconhecer a natureza
búdica em todos os seres, por todas as
direções, né? Isso produz essa essa
conexão aonde o ambiente inteiro
sustenta
a própria manifestação. Se a gente tiver
uma dúvida com respeito a isso, a gente
pode um pouquinho olhar, por exemplo, o
fato da do nosso próprio corpo, né? A
gente tem fígado, que é diferente dos
rins, né? Eh, cada um desses órgãos,
eles também têm uma especificidade. Eles
estão colocados em algum lugar, mas eles
não se isolam. Se a gente isolar o
fígado, aquilo a gente não dura
meio-dia,
né? Qualquer bloqueio dos fluxos assim.
Então, os vários órgãos, eles não
existem para si mesmos, eles existem pro
conjunto. E nós também, nós não
existimos para nós mesmos, nós existimos
pro conjunto. É assim, esse é o ponto.
Aí nós vamos andando.
Então, obrigado, pessoal. Um abraço.
Tudo de bom aí. Se tudo correr bem,
entre hoje, amanhã ou depois de amanhã,
eu apareço lá pelo Sucavate.
Um beijo grande.
>> Obrigada, Lama.
>> Vem para São Paulo, Lama.
>> Convida. Eu nem vou.
>> Beijo.
>> Vem pro Ceará. Vem pro Ceará.
>> Vem para São Paulo. Lama.
>> Agora começa a aparecer os convites. Eu
tava lá abandonado. Ninguém me
>> Vi a mão.
>> Vi a mão. Eu vou. Eu vou hoje, eu vou a
mão com certeza. Obrigado.
>> Gratidão.
>> Beijo.
>> Boa viagem.
>> Obrigado, Lama. Gratidão. Um beijo aí
pra Valéria.
>> Saudades, Valéria. Tudo de bom. Ganha
agosto eu vou vou te encontrar, eu acho.
>> Sim.
>> Vemos em Campinas, então.
>> Beijo grande.
>> Diga lá. Beijo, Lão.
Beijo. Então, tchau.
>> Vai afiando as perguntas que eu em
agosto tô aí.
Muito contente já aqui vibrando com a
tua vinda. Obrigada.
>> Um beijo então.
>> Tchau. Tchau. Tchau.
>> Segura aí, Gil. Se não for barrado na
portaria, eu apareço aí.
Essa não, eu acho que eu não vou não.
Tá bom. Beijo, pessoal.
>> Beijo.
>> Tchau.
Obrigado.
>> Dá tchau. Dá tchau.
Rico.
>> Tchau.
Tchau.
>> Maria da Paz.
Oi, queridona. Beijo, viu?